en este vídeo hablaremos de la teoría
cuantitativa del dinero que se basa en
lo que se conoce como la ecuación de
cambio que intenta relacionar la oferta
de dinero que de notaremos como m la
cual es una medida de la oferta
monetaria y la relación con el pib real
y este es el pib real también lo
relaciona con el nivel de precios nivel
de precios que en un momento lo haremos
más tangible y también introduce la idea
de la velocidad del dinero que es una
medida de qué tan rápido circula la
oferta monetaria es decir si hay un peso
cuantas veces por año cambia de mano la
ecuación de cambio que se utiliza en la
teoría cuantitativa del dinero relaciona
todo esto de la siguiente manera la
oferta de dinero por la velocidad del
dinero es igual a el nivel de precios
por
el pib real que lo podemos ver en una
base anual
pero ahora tratemos de hacer esto más
tangible haciendo que la velocidad sea
tangible por ejemplo supongamos que nos
encontramos en un mundo en donde tenemos
una oferta monetaria de 10 mil millones
de pesos que en realidad es una economía
muy pequeña pero supongamos que esta es
la oferta y vamos a decir que nuestro
pib real en este año de nuestra economía
es de 100 mil millones de pesos 100 mil
millones de pesos por año y supongamos
que el nivel de precios donde
generalmente se usa en índices es de 1.1
entonces si multiplicamos el nivel de
precios por el pib real este producto
nos dará el pib nominal en donde si esto
fuera 1.0 entonces sería una referencia
a algún año que consideremos nuestro año
base así que este es nuestro pib real en
términos de este año base y cuando
multiplicamos por el índice
2 obtenemos el pib nominal pero dada
esta información pausa en el vídeo y
traten de calcular la velocidad de
dinero para ese año bueno esto es
álgebra relativamente sencilla para
despejar b necesitamos dividir ambos
lados entre m entonces obtenemos que la
velocidad de dinero en este año es igual
al nivel de precios por nuestro pib real
entre la cantidad de dinero y esto es
igual a 1.1 por 100.000 millones de
pesos al año entre 10 mil millones de
pesos y esto a que es igual vamos a ver
1.1 por 100 es 110 entre 10 es igual a
11 entonces nos queda que esto es igual
a 11 las unidades en pesos se cancelan y
sólo nos queda 11 por año entonces una
forma de interpretar esto es que con
estos valores el peso promedio circular
a 11 veces por año pero
y esta idea todavía les parece muy
abstracta piénsenlo de esta manera
supongamos que tenemos una economía
extrema en donde sólo tenemos dos partes
y supongamos que nuestro nivel de
precios es simplemente uno con lo que el
pib real es igual al pit nominal y
supongamos que este año nuestro pib es
de 100 mil millones de pesos 100 mil
millones de pesos por año pero hacemos
una situación extrema en donde la
cantidad de dinero que tenemos también
es de 100 mil millones de pesos bueno si
en este mundo solamente hay dos personas
en esta economía o tal vez esta persona
le paga a estas 100 mil millones de
pesos ese dinero cambio de mano una vez
por lo que en esta situación la
velocidad del dinero sería de una vez
por año pero imaginen otro escenario en
donde en lugar de que m sea igual a 100
mil millones de pesos ahora supongamos
que me es igual a un peso y aún podemos
tener un pib de 100 mil millones de
pesos
porque ese peso puede cambiar de manos
100 mil millones de veces claro tendría
que suceder rápidamente para que un peso
cambie tanto en un año por ejemplo esta
persona puede comprar algo de esta
persona que valga un peso y esta persona
puede comprar algo de esta que valga un
peso y ese dinero va y viene 100 mil
millones de veces entonces en esta
situación en donde todavía tenemos el
mismo pib real y nominal si la cantidad
de dinero es de 100 mil millones de
pesos entonces la velocidad tendría que
ser 100 mil millones de veces mayor
ahora las personas a las que les gusta
pensar en esta ecuación de cambio y la
teoría cuantitativa del dinero
generalmente se conocen como
monetaristas y los monetaristas creen
que la inflación es fundamentalmente un
fenómeno monetario en donde se
incrementa la oferta monetaria eso
aumenta la inflación y si la disminuimos
eso hace que la inflación vaya más lenta
incluso puede resultar en deflación
entonces si queremos pensar en la
inflación en términos de dinero podemos
despejar p de esta ecuación para eso
vamos a dividir ambos lados entre el pib
real y así obtenemos que el nivel de
precios es igual a la cantidad de dinero
por la velocidad entre el pib real y los
monetaristas suponen que la velocidad es
constante aunque algunas personas tienen
la teoría de que tal vez no es constante
porque por ejemplo la tecnología puede
hacer más fáciles las gestiones con lo
que la velocidad incrementa o también
podría ser un mundo en donde la forma de
pensar de las personas hace que más o
menos puedan gestionar su dinero lo que
cambia la velocidad pero los
monetaristas generalmente tienden a
suponer que esto es constante porque eso
permite que se puedan hacer conclusiones
a partir de esta ecuación de cambio
los monetaristas también suponen que los
cambios en la oferta monetaria no tienen
un impacto en la producción a largo
plazo entonces por emme a largo plazo si
suponemos que estas dos cosas son
relativamente constantes entonces
veremos esta relación directa entre el
nivel de precios y la cantidad de dinero
en la práctica este es un ejemplo muy
simplificada como la mayoría de nuestros
modelos económicos por ejemplo en la
recesión anterior de 2008 a 2009
la reserva federal practicó la
flexibilización cuantitativa en donde
aumentaron dramáticamente la oferta
monetaria pero no vimos un aumento
dramático en la inflación es decir en el
nivel de precios ahora algunas personas
podrían decir que en 2008 cuando la
reserva federal incrementó
dramáticamente la oferta monetaria sin
un incremento del nivel de precios tal
vez fue porque la velocidad de dinero se
encontraba muy baja las personas no
estaban comprando o vendiendo con todo
ese dinero que había sido inyectado en
el sistema quién sabe pero si siempre
podemos usar la velocidad del dinero
como un factor constante quizá eso pone
en debate qué tan útil podría ser esto
pero es necesario mencionar que es un
modelo interesante para razonar si la
oferta monetaria incrementa
dramáticamente y las personas compran y
venden aproximadamente con la misma
velocidad tal vez la producción actual
de la economía no cambia entonces de
alguna manera tiene sentido decir que
tal vez eso podría aumentar el nivel de
precios porque tenemos más dinero con la
misma producción
nos vemos en otro vídeo